came to this 15-minute game I'm playing
hmm rainia Doris from the US right okay
neither 365 I could okay let's go let's
play a proper english i could play you
for going back to the sicilian but let's
just do something that I know the moment
I feel like not being in terribly good
shape so better stay within the thing
the things that I know I think I played
a bit too much Chester recent times it
happens yeah the maracas see bind has
already mentioned on some occasions one
of my favorite openings maybe my
favorite I cannot really remember that I
ever lost a tournament game with that
this is not in in recent memory and have
one at all I mean really a ton I lost
with blackness in the maracas see
sometimes when i was trying it on the
black side ok i played this night see to
move that i really like a lot avoiding
further exchanges the more pieces stay
on the board the more problems black
hairs he's got less space and would
really like to trade some pieces
yeah the other general problem and this
is a typical thing for the whole let's
say dragon family of openings is the d5
square white very often can plant a
knight on d5 and this is not a tub not
oral tolerable for a long time black
will often need to take it and then you
will suffer from some serious space
disadvantage in the center ok I'm
covering this year you can try bishop e6
but not sure that it is really leading
too much I always have 95 on that and at
some point black needs to attend the
threat to a seven you're a wage five
that's a bit surprising i really i
really don't intend to play b form yeah
maybe he wants to play Bishop h6 at some
point maybe yeah what about this a seven
polar bear ksb 6 i'm probably trapping
it yeah not a good idea but i can i can
threaten to take it maybe after 95 or
because you want first yeah maybe 95
before he gets into queen a5 this age
five move is really am really a problem
for black this is sometimes an idea in
the barrack see if you manage to
exchange the bishop on age six or you
can sometimes you have positions where
the Queen can go to age 8 and sort of
use the long diagonal that's a very far
away here and another problem is that
this h5 move makes it somewhat more
difficult for black to move the f pawn
for instance after trade on d5 sometimes
f5 is the source of current
here combining h 5 + + f5 would really
weaken him a lot okay b6 just securing
the a7 palm but now after a CAPTCHA on
d5 see takes d5 the C file and this is 6
squared particular will be a problem
yeah I need to strengthen this a bit the
root belongs here anyway and I'm not
quite sure what black is doing actually
I I expected that and now i have not be
five this was my idea and night to be
five without him being able to take it
the night can sometimes just go to d
fourth oh this is a big concession now i
get get very nice play on the C file i
think i will take with the pond yep I
mean I need to take with the pawn anyway
but II takes d5 is often also very good
here here it would have been quite
interesting even because fy5 is much
stronger with age 5 being played yeah
but this was my my intention now I'm
coming in with Bishop b5 Bishop a6 these
kind of ideas it's just a very very
convenient end game or yeah it can be an
end game with black starts the trade of
things now Brooksie one box you want
Luke c8 it's just a very nice position
for white
yeah maybe you can play Queen B 7 at
least preventing Bishop a 69 SLFP should
be five and can use the weekend c6
square yeah I played this in a fairly
simplistic manner but still on the C
file in the c6 square are very promising
this is a position which really is
defined completely by this movie 6 if
black wouldn't have played b6 yeah like
a six instead of b6 the whole thing is
this world with a six and said I'll be
60 why this is somewhat better Mia to
Bishop space and so on but it's nothing
really am nothing concrete until I have
this direct way to UM to use the the
weekend the weekend scram ok let's just
go there immediately
very tough to defend a six Bishop c6
it's very annoying this piece and I can
still combine the play on the sea island
on c6 with the with the later advance on
the kingside like f4 at the moment
therefore is never really possible as if
i was hanging but it's not something I
need to do immediately I think black
should try to exchange as much as
possible Brooksie one rook c8 yeah not
much choice I mean I wanted to go there
anyway
yeah I think bear well black should take
right in better Queen somewhere okay
takes hmm yeah taking with the pawn it's
not that convincing but I wanted to take
with the night anyway Boone just keep
this piece on c6 is just our just very
very problematic would like to live with
that
yeah what's my next plan based on this
night you may be a 4 b4 b5 just
cementing this not a bad idea he wants
to play you 64 counterplay maybe Bishop
g5 so that after you six I can I can
just take it one of six I mean or Bishop
g4 yeah well then bishop age six is not
helping
hmm now that's not so so clear-cut when
he gets to play a six what if I directly
attack here Queen f2 attacking b6 that's
the lesson six
hmm I'm not sure I should play Bishop g4
e6 and then take it opieop g5 and then
take it the dark square some are really
a problem that's not so easy actually
after e6 takes texts as always is 95
thread maybe Bishop f4 just attacking d6
and on e6 ignore it now that sets may be
a good idea maybe do that I don't know I
wanted to play move now finally so e 6
i'll just i'll just keep the tension and
claimed that after ed 585 I'm attacking
d 6mm e6 Bishop t6 immediately can take
d5 and play Queen d7 on this is not
really great I lose back the pond ok but
now i have before right or b4 b5
yeah okay come on let's let's play that
yes if he goes to be 62 c 4 that's
that's a problem I need to to cover that
but on the other hand an ID on b6 okay
what I'm getting at is I go here and
play 95 just your town and now i have 95
and possibly rook c6 night b6 there's
also night a 5mm Queen a7 Queen f2
that's nice with a deadly pin
yeah that looks nice now this be five
more surprised me yeah night if Knight
a5 is a very important additional
resource I wonder if you maybe can play
night exactly night down the night a
five is not leading to that much can go
to d7
yeah remarkably resilient all this yeah
I played a couple of bad moves that sir
more likely um yeah what am I doing here
now yeah taking only five leads to
absolutely nothing and 95 fine what
exactly is the point down strange he not
sure we are why I did something wrong
yeah this night c4 I cannot play
something like Quincy to weigh just
place 94 yeah maybe this is keeping some
pieces on the board amazing yeah but
what what did I do wrong there yeah I
really don't know I mean black plated
ton of strange moves and it should
really be enough to be in really big
trouble and he somehow isn't I mean it's
not nice but it's not like Brett black
is resigning any minute now can just
blow 27 does not play that hmm the
surety for you know not not sure
reliever perfect yeah 10 still going to
try to do something here
yeah bishop deform is planning to play F
for the right moment or maybe in some
cases take on e5 and then go back to z 6
yeah everything Queen d7 was the the
tougher way to play yeah oh I don't I
don't really have much choice B should
be three years just just repetition but
I don't mind therefore must be quite
okay
yeah I guess nights FYI 97 looks
terribly passive an IG for I don't know
I didn't know what this should do we am
ok he must must do that probably ok take
it and now you should see three blocking
the pawn yeah but ok it's not going to
to move anytime soon now let's
strengthen that pawn structure bit so
that I can possibly move the Queen now
even this position is not totally clear
cut yeah I need to take ok i was
expecting the other one Brooke tags but
he probably wants to operate with if I
am
yeah there's still quite a number of
pieces on the on this in this diagonal
here with e5 if I've can be a really
tricky move to phase
who
how do i improve this year not so I
don't see it at the moment what's the
best way to play could be i'm thinking
of bishops III and on e5 to play Queen
d5 but he's got Queenie some check and
then take not good
now this this candidiasis checks are
very problematic I wonder if I should
really play King edge 1 yeah come on I
need to play more he five no it's
playing something else yeah that I
really didn't didn't think of okay if I
take it and bishops III attending queen
dee Ford attacking d fire my d5 is
really hanging badly now this must be a
must be covered yeah but maybe just rope
the ATM 24 okie for and this wasn't too
great still not easy
now queen d 40 key for remarkable and
still I cannot play a five how do i get
an f5 cookie i need to move the Queen
away here and still keep Queen after
maybe keeping default under control and
intending to play a 5 f-5 Bishop see one
FG sixes should be winning so this pin
with the bishop on the rook is not so
dramatic d for I can take a maybe this
is still ok yeah but f5 is the five
strong reactable d4 takes should win and
Bishop see one taking a yeah wins
definitely I mean I didn't calculate
that but I cannot believe he can take
still the height take and he goes to h6
is this a mate Bishop takes you one
would be extremely cold blooded take g6
king age 6 nope playing something
different ok i will take yeah i have
quincy to check so Jack take your first
I have various intermediate checks ok
Queen g3 or Quincy to a Quincy to assess
strong though
I guess rookie for the souk f6 and
whether you go I mean you can go to the
F file and now I get to go to h 7 ER and
then it's probably a probably very very
very good King jeeva Bishop t2 is easy
yeah okay what is winning after all but
this was a tough piece of defense by
black yeah but should be 2 is the the
easiest right I can take it yeah taking
it is even easier Queen takes Bishop g2
is winning the queen and king takes
yellow rook f1 this is this is going to
be a maid
black resigns yeah right here I felt
that this must be fantastic for white
and somehow it was still very resilient
maybe this was premature I don't know
and before is better yeah this wasn't it
wasn't really that clear-cut especially
here if you think Queen d7 I mean there
is nothing going on I really am i will
upload it I must played some some not
too great moves and he defended well
only here I think he went wrong again
slightly still is very complicated
position the fire was surprising to me I
thought he should just keep the the
structure as it is but maybe as can do
that now this is not bad for like
probably yeah only here this this is
this is allowing f5 with with deadly
effect or let's say advantage hard
computer wants to play Queen d6 or go
ahead is it now after f5 young it's
probably not a wind of black defense
perfectly rook f8 doesn't move only this
is really yeah yeah yeah this is not
really when you check yeah yeah but what
about about this year I mean this is
really a must be excellent for white
maybe it's just a mistimed procedure but
should be 52 c6 and just I just just
play I should just play a like before
and a3 and those kind of slow moves I
mean don't forget if we if we trade more
pieces and I get an endgame
with the space advantage and the two
bishops wide is in fantastic shape I
don't really need to to do something
spectacular him maybe maybe this wasn't
really helping this transfer of the
bishop okay very tough game thanks for
watching